support for think fast talk smart comes
from stanford continuing studies
stanford continuing studies offers over
150 online classes on a wide range of
topics from art history to ai wellness
to writing as well as courses on
business and communication
fall registration opens august 16th and
is open to all adult learners everywhere
most classes start the week of september
20th learn more at
continuingstudies.stanford.edu
this podcast is dedicated to helping
people deal with everyday business
challenges with confidence and
conviction
however today we're going to take a
different tack we're going to look at
another challenge that many of us face
helping teenagers become adults
and the things that we learn in this
conversation will actually help us be
better in the workplace
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast i am really
looking forward to speaking with julie
lithgot haims julie is multi-talented a
lawyer by training and a former dean of
freshman and undergraduate advising at
stanford she is now a much sought-after
speaker and the author of the
award-winning book how to raise an adult
break free of the over-parenting trap
and prepare your kid for success
julie now has a new book your turn how
to be an adult
thanks for being here julie matt thanks
so much for having me i'm really looking
forward to communicating with you today
excellent me me too let's jump right in
can you define what you mean by the term
adulting and can you share some of the
challenges parents and kids face during
the transition to adulthood
sure thing well i guess i need to start
by giving a nod to the millennial
generation they're the ones who coined
the verb adulting i don't want to adult
i don't know how to adult adulting is
scary
and um
their anguish their angst over not
knowing how or wanting to is really what
led me to write this thing
then i had to examine what adulting
meant and i came up with this as the
definition
adulting is simply the phase of life
between childhood and death
where you're not dependent upon other
people
to plan chart fix manage handle the
stuff of life for you where you have
this delicious freedom and independence
and oh the terrifying
uh knowledge that hey it's kind of on me
to figure this out which is not to say
any of us ever has to go it alone
so that's what adulting is
and the challenges when it comes to
parents and kids is
as parents we grew this child in our
body perhaps or adopted it into our
family or our partner gave birth to it
and we are completely responsible in
those early months and years
but over the course of that child's life
we're supposed to be
slowly moving from being completely in
charge of their life to turning the
reins over to them and i think
this
big leap from the end of high school
the start of college the start of work
the start of military life whatever
awaits after high school
um is
is to leap over a chasm in some ways i
mean there's a sense that oh my gosh
there's a big gap i might fall into or
you know i might not make it and of
course that's not literally true but i
think it's an important moment for us as
parents to be preparing for to be
thinking okay what do i want
to have confidence my kid can do when
they're no longer living in our home
when i'm no longer the primary one
responsible for their food and their
shelter and and their day-to-day
well-being we want to be parenting in
the teenage years and even earlier
toward the inevitability that we all
want this young person to be a
free-standing adult who can fend for
themselves one day
oh and it is so fraught with challenges
i i am going through this now as a
parent myself it sounds like it's really
balancing between freedom and
responsibility both for parents as well
as for kids
what advice and guidance do you have for
helping parents and kids communicate
about some of these challenges and
achieving this balance
you're absolutely right that it's
freedom and responsibility i can hear um
john hennessey who was president um when
i last worked at stanford
every year giving the graduation speech
and really
helping the graduates understand um that
with this freedom and independence comes
responsibility responsibility isn't a
bad thing responsibility is actually an
amazing thing and i think
we parents have to do a better job of
narrating to that truth that is
um you're going to be more
you're going to be responsible for more
of your own
um
things you're going to be responsible
for making sure your homework is in its
bag and taken to school you're going to
be responsible for making your own lunch
you're going to be responsible for
making your own doctor's appointments um
conveying the expectation that these
things will be turned over to the kid
and that that's not a bad thing you're
actually trusting that they either can
already or can almost handle that task
it's really by handing somebody some
additional responsibility which we're
supposed to be doing
increasingly over the years of childhood
we're actually signaling
i believe you can and that turns out
matt to be a really important indicator
of a person's wellness the extent to
which they believe they can do the task
in front of them so a vote of confidence
from a parent saying hey you're going to
be responsible for this now as long as
it's done kindly
as opposed to feeling like your parent
has turned your back on you
it's really quite empowering to be given
additional responsibility and that's how
you know the freedom and the
responsibility really nicely then go
together
so it sounds to me like
part of the challenge is to
set clear expectations uh along the way
but also to
think about the tone in which you're
communicating those messages so that
as you're having these conversations
you're being supportive but also very
clear about what is happening now and
will happen in the future is that right
exactly right i mean i think we're at
our best when when we're parenting when
we're providing unconditional love
a tremendous amount of empathy optimism
that the kid is going to be able to make
their way so the tone of voice the body
language
needs to be that of a
compassionate
yet emotionally
somewhat distant
adult and this may sound a bit odd to
people aren't we parents supposed to be
very close to our kids and kind of why
would you advocate for psychological
distance
what i'm responding to is the
over-parenting tendency which says you
know your homework needs to get done you
need to get an a you need to get into
this college or go off and do this
career so that i feel okay as a parent
that's a psychological
uh intertwinedness that's actually
really unhealthy for both the kid and
for the parent the more healthy distance
is when you can care very much about how
they are you can offer help and guidance
but you're not feeling that you own
every single thing that they do whether
it's their homework or their activities
or their college applications um it's
uh we want to be in this place where our
child has the agency the autonomy to
kind of make their own way and have
their experiences make their choices
fall a little bit here and there pick
themselves up and be stronger based on
what they experienced and um our tone
needs to be even and positive optimistic
kind and loving but never nudging them
like why are you doing it better you
know we we expect better of you or
um
and certainly not being um you know
disinterested um
it's sort of like
picture how loving you can be with your
niece or nephew
or your best friend's kid where you care
about the kid but you don't feel
obligated to tell them precisely what to
do all the time and you don't feel
obligated to solve their problems that's
that's the healthy psychological
distance i think we're going for
actually as parents
i really like that image
that that will be very helpful to me
and hopefully many other folks and and i
like how you highlight it it's not just
about what you say but how you say it
that nonverbal openness uh is really
critical
we have on this podcast talked about
improvisation in in lots of different
ways to help people be present oriented
to help people feel more comfortable
speaking spontaneously you talk about
adopting principles from improv and
design thinking to help when people feel
stuck can you tell us more about this
and how this can help
yeah so a lot of people who are trying
to
spread their wings and and
enter adult land feel stuck
and i think part of that is the sense
that i have to know what i'm doing in
advance i have to be really good at it
before i even start kind of a
perfectionistic tendency i have to know
what i want i have to know who i am and
i think an overarching message of this
new book your turn is hey you don't have
to know you don't have to have it all
figured out um the point is just start
to move in the direction of something
and so both from the d-school
folks and from improv more broadly i've
borrowed the language bias toward action
and start anywhere and i think in in
whether you're a designer or whether
you're an improv actor trying to
entertain an audience it's just all
about let's go let's just try something
let's this isn't about it has to be
perfect this is just about what can
happen when we leave this
point we're stuck in or standing in our
comfort zone perhaps or our our stuck
zone perhaps and just take a step in any
direction you will learn something you
will have an experience you will you
know analyze the data how you felt you
know what you might do differently and
all of that begins to create some
velocity
forward
the the bias towards action is such a
powerful lesson from both design
thinking and improv and it plays out in
lots of ways in our relationships and in
our communication
uh there's there's a corollary to to
that notion which is you know good is
great good enough is great and it's this
notion that we put a lot of pressure on
ourselves and one of the reasons we
don't move forward is we're afraid it
won't go the way we want or it won't be
as good as it could be and just giving
ourselves permission to to move forward
is really really powerful
in your book your turn
you have a chapter entitled start
talking to strangers
can you explain the advice you give in
this chapter and share any breath best
practices you have that can help people
use communication to connect with others
yeah
i think that chapter opens by saying
this or in the first couple of
paragraphs this may be the most obvious
point i make in the book but every
single human is a stranger to you at the
outset
deliberately um
subverting the childhood norm don't talk
to strangers which
young adults were raised with and making
the point that this was an overbroad
rule
the rule should have been learn let me
teach you how to discern the one creepy
stranger from the vast majority of
humans who are perfectly fine child you
know let me let you walk through the
world with me watching how i discern
whether a stranger is okay to talk to
instead we've given this over broad rule
don't talk to strangers and
many many many many young people really
don't know how to be they feel afraid
they feel unsure they feel something's
wrong if stranger is trying to talk to
them
um and that's boy if there's anything
that's got inhibited
um or really prevented um a normal
free-flowing conversation between people
who've not previously met
this mantra don't talk to strangers you
know may be it yeah well um you know
we shouldn't blanket blanket rules
rarely apply right
in the instinct about how to approach
somebody um you're going to have to talk
to strangers when you leave your family
home you're going to go to a college or
community college or the workplace or
the military there will be people who
have information that you need there
will be people who can help you on your
path there will be people that you can
help
and you know all of those things are
going to require us
opening our mouths and and talking to
this person
but that's not all i mean we've got to
be respectful toward this other person
we've got to also have a sense of how to
advocate for ourselves communication is
you know such a delicate dance and
kids need to emerge from childhood
having practiced
matt here's here's a fascinating thing
that that uh i end up putting in the
pages of your turn that i got from
psychologists and stanford alum laurie
gottlieb she says julie so many young
adults don't know how to communicate
with their
uh significant others or their let's you
know their boyfriend their girlfriend
the person they're dating and they show
up in her therapy practice and they say
oh i broke up with my boyfriend we had
an argument and he wasn't 100 there for
me so i just i dropped him and she says
julie here's what i think is going on
their childhood communication
conversations were so regulated by
well-meeting parents teachers other
adults who sorted out difficulties when
kids weren't getting along on the
playground or on a play date who gave
the kids language to use to talk to the
other kids i'm not trusting the kids
could ever figure this out themselves
with a little bit of guidance right a
lot of adults did that handling now
we've got a set of young adults
who haven't had that practice on the
playground in playdates in group play
with their peers and they think that
when someone loves them it means i'll
drop everything to support you you know
parents basically behave that way like
you're not happy school i'll go argue
with the teacher for you and instead of
letting the student practice the child
practice how to have a difficult
conversation with somebody so they
become this young adult
who doesn't have the skills to
communicate in what we would call
run-of-the-mill situations a
conversation with a friend a
conversation with a with a lover a
conversation with a with a colleague or
a boss
um we've got to let our kids we
we need to want for our kids to practice
practice practice communicating with
their fellow humans well before they
ever leave our homes if they're to make
it in the world one day
the notion of of practice and and giving
space to learn how to communicate better
is so important and then helping them i
can imagine you would agree with this to
reflect on that communication so you can
learn from it and do it differently or
better is also a valuable skill to add
there absolutely
so i'm going to ask you to get a little
meta here julie if that's okay
i have seen you speak on a number of
occasions and you are a phenomenal
speaker and and actually a great meeting
facilitator as well and and those two
don't always go together can you share
some of the things you think about and
do to prepare yourself and your content
before you present or facilitate
yeah it feels a little personal but i'm
not i'm i'm not criticizing or
critiquing i'm just acknowledging
um that i am going to tell you that the
honest true and
honest to god truth here please
i am spiritual but not religious
and as a way to kind of get my
mindfulness game going um i uh when i'm
backstage about to give a big talk
i offer what some might call a prayer um
i am trying to summon my gratitude for
where i am and for what's about to
happen
um and for something that's you know
whatever's going on in my life
i then ask you know please let me have
access to my
um
to my intellect to my sense of humor to
my intuition let me connect
let me help everybody here somehow feel
seen in the message i'm trying to
deliver um i'm centering myself
i'm trying to create space between
wherever i just was you know hurrying to
get there if i'm late pre-pandemic you
know the traffic was bad or you know i
left too late or or um i'm a little
stressed i just try to put a buffer
between everything that came up to that
you know that happened before that
moment and the moment that i'm entering
i'm trying to create a new container
which the conversation whether it's a
speech to an audience or
a conversation among humans where i am
just one of you know i'm i'm a fraction
of the of the whole
i'm trying to be intentional about
the
what i need to do to create a safe and
welcoming and interesting and engaging
conversational experience
wow
thank you first for sharing that and and
second uh so many things going on in
that ritual that you go through that are
so helpful
the ability to be present and getting
yourself in the present moment focusing
through what you call prayer others call
mantra just focusing on the strengths
that you bring to the situation many of
us feel so intimidated and think about
all the deficiencies we have before we
communicate in front of others and and
to focus on our strengths can only help
and to really think about the experience
i love that idea of the container that's
being created in in and thinking about
that experience can only help so so many
lessons to learn in in what you just
shared in and so many lessons to learn
in watching you speak and facilitate
before we end uh i'd like to ask you the
same three questions i ask everyone who
joins me on this podcast are you up for
that i'm up for it matt excellent number
one if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title
what would that be
stop using slides
[Music]
that might be the best answer to that
question given that i'm asking for a
slide title excellent tell me more tell
me what slides what what is it about
slides that bother you yeah well i think
some people do manage to use slides
quite artfully as a way to enhance
whatever it is they're doing with their
body language right and their actual
language but too too many of us doesn't
matter how
many degrees you have or what role you
play of importance in the world really
rely on the slide to tell the story um
to tell the experience people end up
glazing over they read your slide
instead of reading you yes and look my
work is about connecting with humans
human to human i actually am interested
in the energy that we can create that
exists in our bodies that we can we can
sort of strengthen and raise and share
and receive from others and so my work
when i'm this is what makes the pandemic
so hard for a speaker like me i'm trying
to
create energy through you know a zoom
experience and a webcam but um i'm
really interested in like what can you
feel radiating from
um the message that i am delivering and
the slide i think if i was to use slides
and you could probably tell from my
answer that i don't um i would just use
imagery some kind of
image to enhance rather than words i
think it's too confusing
allow me to go to question number two
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
oprah winfrey and oak has had um
a resurgence not to say oprah wasn't
ever always on our minds but you know
she did this amazing interview recently
with um harry and megan yeah and um so
we all billions of people got to see her
again but i began watching oprah i think
she her afternoon chicago based talk
show was on
when i was either in late my late high
school years certainly my college years
she conveyed
such a mad respect for humans
a deep curiosity about the why behind
people's actions and language
and um ultimately could be having a
really tough conversation with somebody
because the topic was tough or because
what they did was difficult bad wrong
etc or concerning but she managed to
to elucidate difficult subjects without
judgment
and
i thought it was the most profound
intersection of curiosity respect and
truth i mean oprah was always going to
tell her own truth but you would feel
even if she was disagreeing with you you
would feel
kind of held
uh
in her arms as she did it and i just
thought that was magnificent
i i like the way you dissected that
curiosity respect and truth and and
certainly she is an expert at all of
that
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe
maya angelou i believe said
they're not going to remember what you
said
they're going to remember how they felt
when you said it
matt for 10 years i had the distinct
humbling joy of being the dean of
freshman on the stanford campus and i
got to give a big speech
many big speeches in a year but
orientation is what i'm thinking of and
in the noise of orientation 200 events
across six or seven days i knew whatever
i said
was not going to be memorable you know
if they were drinking from a fire hose
right yes just trying not to get wet
just trying not to drown and yet we
wanted some of that water to land
because it would be nourishing and so i
aimed
to convey that feeling right you may you
will probably not re remember the words
but hopefully you are having an
experience of being
respected and um and um helped and aided
and cared about and rooted for
um so i think that's the the advice yes
you're going to use words but what is it
ultimately that you hope the recipient
the listener the reader is going to take
away my new book your turn the narrative
voice of that took me three years to
kind of find and hone and it ultimately
is trying to be me it's me trying to be
this
compassionate
frank older person saying i know you're
terrified i get that it's valid
and the thing is you gotta you gotta
step into the adult place
and i'm here rooting for you and i'm
gonna be alongside you on these pages
and you're gonna be okay yes you yes yes
you will and to try to do that on the
page i mean readers will have to let me
know did i succeed or not and maybe in
some chapters i did and others i didn't
but that's um
it's trying to imagine how the other
person is going to receive any of the
stuff you have to offer
and instead of focusing too much on who
am i and how am i what do i think about
it from their perspective it'll take
some of the pressure off you i think and
it allows you to create empathy for your
reader your listener your audience and
ultimately that's going to lead to a
great presentation a great communication
the notion of focusing on your audience
and what they need is a recurrent theme
that we hear across these podcast
episodes what you've added to it around
this notion of really thinking about the
experience and the feeling is very very
important as as well
thank you for that
thank you for all of your time and your
insights your ideas about support
compassion both for ourselves and for
the young adults we're talking to is
critical and these lessons extend well
beyond transitioning into adulthood
i encourage everyone to take time to
read julie's books and to watch her
talks thank you so much julie
matt thanks for having me and to all the
listeners thanks for spending time with
me today i appreciate it
thank you for listening to think fast
talk smart
the podcast a production of stanford
graduate school of business to learn
more go to gsb.stanford.edu
please download other episodes wherever
you find your podcasts